Tony Boselli was on the sidelines last
night working for Westwood One the
former Pro Bowl tackle for the Jags he
joins us getting ready to take off on
his on a plane from Cleveland and kind
enough to join us Tony have you seen
anything like that before well you know
it's interesting in the moment you're
sitting there just describing the action
and obviously it's intense and Marquis
pounces coming in and protecting this
guy and in doing maybe what a little too
far but I think he's doing an offensive
lineman supposed to do protect this
quarterback and and then you kind of get
back out and okay start reading on you
know they're in a Twitter and kind of
you know full flashing back and
reflecting on what happened and usually
you read and you heard I've never seen
anything like that and I think this is
in a culture today where that is a
terrible situation it's inexcusable
miles good day but we always react to
saying this is the worst thing ever
we'll just go back to the late 70s and
early 80's and watch t enough the help
in the highlights and go watch it but
why are they throwing the helmet at the
Jets off its linemen after he lifts it
off and so these things have happened
they're rare thankfully there's no place
for it is you cannot use the helmet as a
weapon and I think severe punishment for
it but you know unfortunately if there's
a lot of emotions and guys loses
sometimes and just snap and things
happen that people regret yeah but you
didn't have social media back in the 70s
and the 80s and that's where you get the
outrage Tony and I'm wondering do you
suspend my as is the rest of the season
enough punishment for you yeah it is I
think that's a huge punishment sex him
financially affect you know his
reputation is individually you know what
he loves to do is also a really hurt the
team he's the best defensive player he's
probably the best player on that team
and to lose him down the stretch is
going to make it much more difficult for
them big house which is a huge impact
for the whole organization so for me the
six games is enough it sends a message
that you can't this is there's no place
for it and you know if you go through
Miles Garrett's young career you know
he's had some pushing and shoving
matches done things like that but
there's never been a suspension there's
never been a major issue on the field
with him we
in that way as an offensive lineman how
do you defend what Pouncy did I I'm
telling you Dan I said it last night on
the broadcast I'm not sure I wouldn't do
much different because as an offensive
lineman your sole job is to protect that
guy and you're the envy of the guys out
there trying to make sure nothing
happens to him and when you turn and see
a defensive player swinging his helmet
and contacting your quarterback all bets
are off at that point and you got to go
after the guy you got to protect your
guy
now the kicking you know at the end of
it was probably that's too much but at
the same time I'm not gonna sit here and
go after Pouncy because I'm not sure I
was done anything different moving
forward if you were going to invest in
one of these two teams browns after the
win or the Steelers after the loss well
miles Garrett would have been mouth
Garrett's still on that team for the
recipe I go with the Browns because I
just I'm not a believer Mason Rudolph's
I just don't see it and within their
inability to run the ball effectively a
tall fence line struggle this year and
they really struggled last night go from
running and passing protected I think
that defense which was outstanding last
night yeah they gave the 21 points but
they were putting Schwartz fields all
night really get two big players out I
did they're really good
I'm just not sure you know it's enough
what makes a new job now both teams have
really eaten schedules the Browns are
the easiest schedule for the rest of the
year and I think Steelers a second now
that's what happens when the Cincinnati
Bengals in division so both of them are
still right in the thick of it but
probably you know of a slight edge to
the Browns but Steelers have a better
record so we'll see Tony I keep coming
back to this team with all the penalties
undisciplined last night maybe a
microcosm of that with what happened
with Miles Garrard and comes back to the
shoulders of Freddie kitchens your
thoughts on Freddie kitchens keeping
this job well I think we were waiting
with premature as I we judged
the Browns organization them as a team
they have a young quarterbacks like your
guy did go to growing pains we're seeing
that this year just because you
accumulate a bunch of stars that doesn't
make them a team and it takes a
seasoned veteran coach I think can
really manage the personalities and
that's not what Freddie kitchens is I
mean a year ago he was running backs
coach to start the season got promoted
off Flint's corner next thing you know
because Baker likes them and they have a
good rapport they make him the head
coach so he's learning on the job
I think Reddy's a good guy doing the
best he can but every situation is V to
him and that's tough especially when you
have as many personalities and high
expectations that were put on this year
when's the last time you set middle seed
coach it was about it was about this
seven eight months ago what happened was
out of first class C but I was gonna
have it like a two and a half three hour
layover in Atlanta and I had to make the
decision I go stand by get a middle seat
it's only 45 minutes flight to
Jacksonville or wait three hours and I
had been on the road for a long time I
was tired and I said I'll suck it up and
I really felt sorry for the two people
said 19 is my rear end and everything
was overflowing to both sides official
hiding wait for Tony Boselli is well
it's over 67 I might be shrinking a
little bit so it might be a flat 6 7 the
weight is something I really not proud
of right now it's over 300 pounds again
and that's not a good thing especially
if you're sitting next to you in code
hey safe travels back great to hear from
you again Tony thank you that's Tony was
selling we're all-pro tackle working for
Westwood one he's the sideline reporter
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV streamed
for free on BR Live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]